اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط
وجندي وجرحى 66 اخرين في معارك قطاع غزه
خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي يقول ان سحب الجيش من
مراكز حماس في غزه خطا فادح وخطير وسيكلف
اسرائيل ارواحا بشريه وكتائب القسام تعلن
قصف مدينه نتيفوت الاسرائيليه برشقه
صاروخيه وتقول انها اشتبكت مع قوه مشاه
للاحتلال غربه للهواء واوقعت افرادها بين
قتيل وجريح شهداء وجرحى في قصف اسرائيلي
على مخيم جباليا ومدينه غزه وخانيونس
الصحه في غزه تقول ان القصف المتواصله ادى
الى استشهاد
158 فلسطينيا خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
ورئيس الوزراء القطري يؤكد وجوب العمل على
انهاء الحرب في غزه سريعا واطلاق الرهائن
والسجناء الفلسطينيين قوات الاحتلال تقتحم
مدينه قلقيليه شماليه الضفه الغربيه ومخيم
عين سلطان شمال مدينه ارحا مسؤولون امنيون
اسرائيليون يحذرون من ان الضفه الغربيه
على شفى الانفجار والجيش الاسرائيلي ينقل
وحده دوف دفان من غزه الى الضفه تحسبا
لتصاعد الاوضاع شركه شحن يابانيه تعلن
تعليق الملاحه عبر البحر الاحمر لجميع
سفنها اعتبارا من اليوم القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه تقول انها ضبطت اسلحه ايرانيه
متقدمه كانت متجهه الى الحوثيين وفي اجراء
هو الاول من نوعه سفن وناقلات قباله سواحل
جيبوتي تضع عباره لا علاقه لنا باسرائيل
في لوحات التعريف الالي الخاصه بها الى
اللقاء